governors u.s. states bordering Mexico
or welcoming president Trump's move to
send National Guard troops to the border
the President signed a proclamation last
night saying the combination of illegal
drugs dangerous gang activity and
extensive illegal immigration not only
threatens our safety but also undermines
the rule of law homeland security
secretary that's Kirsten Nielson says
the DHS and the Pentagon will work with
governor's to deploy the guard she did
not say how many troops would go federal
law prohibits the military from carrying
out domestic law enforcement unless
authorized by Congress Nielsen says
illegal border crossings are increasing
according to Customs and Border Patrol
border arrests are down more than 12
percent from this time last year but
more than 37,000 people were apprehended
in March that's the most in one month
since mr. Trump took office CBS News
military and homeland security analyst
sandy Winnefeld when it failed pardon me
is a retired Navy admiral he's a former
vice chairman of the Joint Chiefs of
Staff and joins us from Washington
Admiral good morning good morning John
how are you very well thank you for
joining us
so this 37,000 number that does seem
like a spar a spike in March President
George W Bush sent the National Guard
Barack Obama President Obama sent the
National Guard so is this just in
keeping with what presidents do good
question John for one thing the spike in
March is fairly well explainable by a
simple thing called the whether there is
a cyclic --all urban flow of illegal
immigration along the border that
corresponds to the spring months and the
fall months when the weather is a little
nicer for people the leisure to survive
that trip in terms of whether this is
something that presidents do it appears
to be the case President Bush sent 6,000
National Guard troops to the border
during his administration and President
Obama sent 1,200 if I recall and it
remains to be seen how many president
Trump intends to this order seem
different to you we've established that
all president that presidents have done
it but does this particular order seem
different or no not really well it seems
a little different in that when
Presidents Bush and Obama sent Guard
troops to the border it was because of a
spike a real large historical spike in
illegal
immigration it's almost as though the
spikes occur in even-numbered years and
perhaps there's one happening this year
but as you pointed out earlier this is a
historically low time for illegal
immigration so it does seem a little
strange that we would be sending guards
to the border at this particular time so
Admiral if the weather is part of what
causes this or might cause it then
shouldn't it have been something the
administration should have anticipated
and also what will the guard do when
they're there
well the guard of course if it's
directed by the President to go to the
border cannot execute law enforcement
tasks so they will provide supporting
tasks to the Border Patrol they can
provide mobility they can enhance the
surveillance that the border protection
forces might do along the border but
they can't actually directly apprehend
individuals so it'll be indirect support
at best
Admiral you've been part of the Joint
Chiefs of Staff so I want to ask you
about what's happening in Syria because
as you know President Trump has
instructed the military to prepare to
withdraw what are the consequences of
that well clearly there are different
views within the administration of
whether the US should withdraw from
Syria or not I think most of the folks
who are operational in this the
diplomats the intelligence folks the
military folks believe that they're
making progress they're invested in this
and they think that they're important US
interests at stake the president on the
other hand came in with an America first
grand strategy and he's asking questions
about whether protecting those interests
is worth the cost and blood and treasure
and he's looking back over many years in
Iraq and Afghanistan where it's a the
difficult job to get done so it's gonna
be interesting to see how this plays out
there are a US interests at stake in
preventing increased Iranian influence
in the region preventing increased
Russian influence in their region trying
to limit the extent of a humanitarian
catastrophe prevent the re-emergence of
missiles so there are plenty of reasons
to be there the question will have to be
resolved in the president's mind and his
advisors minds on whether it's worth the
cost that it could take to get that done
well during the campaign the then
candidate Trump made a lot about
telegraphing what the u.s. was going to
do particularly on the matter of
withdrawing US troops so give us your
assessment in this case he seems to be
telegraphing what the US would do and
what is the one of the benefits are
costs of doing that well candidly it's
it's not unusual for the
to be inconsistencies and statements for
example we know the president was very
critical of the Obama administration in
withdrawing from Iraq during their time
in power and now he's talking about
withdrawing from Syria so it's not at
all surprising to see some
inconsistencies in statements but it
would seem that telegraphing of
withdrawal from Syria would would be in
contrast to a statement that says we
should never tell our adversaries what
we're doing all right Admiral wonderful
always good to see you sir
thanks for you to see you you